voici ce qu'écrit Michel Onfrey dans sa
préface des essais Montaigne est le plus
grand philosophe de l'Occident
judéo-chrétien mais depuis un siècle ou
deux les philosophes officiels ceux de
l'institution et de l'Université des
académies et de la subversion officielle
ne le savent pas pire ils ne veulent pas
le savoir pire que pire ils affirment
même parfois qu'il n'est pas
[Musique]
philosophe d'après Michel hfrey les
philosophes académiques sont jaloux de
Montaigne ils ne veulent pas reconnaître
qu'il a été le premier au 16e siècle à
faire leur découverte philosophique et
ils peuvent être d'autant plus jaloux
que Montaigne lui a une vie bien remplie
il ne s'est pas contenté de fréquenter
les livre avant des cartes il a compris
et affirmé que rien ne remplace le livre
du monde c'est-à-dire les expériences
concrètes au contact des gens comparé
aux érudits de la Renaissance la vie de
Montaigne est donc très originale elle
est pleine d'anecdotes facile an mais
certaines sont
troublantes la famille de Montaigne
appartient à la petite noblesse donc ils
vivent dans un château au sein de leur
domaine en Dordogne la coutume dans ce
milieu social c'est de mettre les
nouveaux nés en nourrice mais le père de
Montaigne s'en fout de la coutume
aristocratique à l'hiver 1533 il confie
donc le nourrisson à de pauvres
bûcherons qui vivent dans un petit
village de son domaine C anecdote révèle
que Montaigne est ce qu'on peut appeler
un métis social avant de connaître le
confort et les privilèges de l'Arist e
il a vécu dès ses premières années avec
les plus humbles du coup sa conscience
sociale est double et c'est l'objectif
de son père il veut non seulement
habituer son fils au mode de vie le plus
simple mais surtout l'attacher
émotionnellement au peuple ça va le
conditionner à remplir ses devoirs
d'aristocrate envers les plus modestes
on peut trouver que la décision du père
est rude surtout pour les toutes
premières années de son enfant et
peut-être que ça aurait pu traumatiser
l'enfant mais Montaigne lui-même
estimera que c'était une très bonne idée
il sera reconnaissant à son père de de
l'avoir libéré des préjugés d'bau et il
dira même que s'il avait tu des fils il
aurait fait la même
chose à 4 ans Montaigne est de retour au
château il se produit un phénomène
étonnant au cours des années suivantes
certains mots et prénoms latins se
mettent à circuler jusque loin dans les
villages voisins or seul les érudit et
la haute société parlent le latin à
l'époque si des mots latins se diffuse
dans les classes inférieures dans le
domaine des montaagnes c'est parce que
le père force les domestiques du château
à sad rend latin à son fils alors bien
sûr les domestiques ne deviennent pas
bilingues ils apprennent simplement les
mots expressions et phrases dont ils ont
besoin au quotidien dans leurs
interactions avec l'enfant cette
anecdote révèle que Montaigne est le
produit d'une expérience éducative son
père qui est très cultivé sait
l'importance du latin pour faire simple
c'est la langue de l'élite et comme il a
de l'ambition pour son fils il veut
qu'il maîtrise parfaitement le latin
mais il sait aussi que l'apprentissage
du latin est particulièrement pénible
ses amis humanistes lui ont expliqué
qu'il est possible d'apprendre
naturellement sans effort sans rigueur
ni contrainte donc il applique cette
idée pour le latin comment est-ce qu'il
s'y prend concrètement il fait venir au
château un éudi allemand qui a une
maîtrise parfaite du latin mais ne parle
pas un mot de français ça lui coûte très
cher mais l'éducation de son fils est
très importante pour lui il adjoint même
à l'érudit allemand deux assistants eux
aussi érudis ces trois hommes ont
l'interdiction totale de parler à
Montaigne dans une autre langue que le
latin mais comment est-ce que les autres
personnes du château la mère le père
lui-même et puis les de
comment doivent-ils parler à l'enfant
s'il lui parle en français son immersion
linguistique en latin ne sera pas totale
et le père craint que cela ne dégrade la
qualité du latin de son fils il impose
donc une autre règle la famille et les
domestiques doivent d'abord se faire
inculquer par les érudits les bribes de
latin nécessaire pour s'adresser à
l'enfant résultat à 6 ans Montaigne
parle parfaitement le latin et il a
appris cette langue sans manuel sans
grammaire sans effort vous pouvez
appliquer les mêmes principes pour
apprendre une langue étrangère d'après
l'hypothèse de l'input du linguiste
Stephen crashen la meilleure manière
d'apprendre une langue est d'être exposé
à des messages qu'on comprend donc au
lieu de mémoriser des listes de
vocabulaire et des règles de grammè il
vaut mieux lire et écouter plein de
choses dans la langue qu'on veut
apprendre en s'assurant qu'on comprend
le sens général en fait il suffit de
refaire avec une langue étrangère ce
qu'on a fait pour apprendre sa langue
maternelle l'expérimentation menée par
le père de Montaigne vise à ce que son
fils le dépasse en maîtrise du latin et
plus généralement qu'il le dépasse
intellectuellement après il y a des
choses que l'éducation ne peut pas
changer Montaigne est minuscule comme
son père étant donné que les plus grands
chevaliers du Moyen-Âge mesuraient à
peine 1,60 Montaigne est probablement
autour d' 1,40 à lire ce qu'il en dit
dans les essais il n'est pas trop
complexé par sa taille mais il déplore
tout de même deux inconvénients d'abord
ça attire l'attention et puis ça amoindr
son
autorité à 25 ans célibataire dissipé
Montaigne et conseillé dans une cours de
Périgueux spécialisé dans les affaires
fiscales c'est pas super prestigieux
donc c'est de justesse qu'il est invité
à une fête des membres du parlement de
Bordeaux il y rencontre un autre
magistrat de 3 ans son aîné ettienne de
la boessie c'est le coup de foudre
amical ainsi n'est une des plus célèbres
amitié de l'histoire occidentale les
deux plus grands penseurs français du
16e siècle l'auteur du fameux discours
de la servitude volontaire et celui des
fameux essais labessie et Montaigne
vivent une fusion affective et
intellectuelle inséparable il partagent
toutes leurs émotions et toutes leurs
pensées ils se comprennent mutuellement
à un niveau très profond comme si leur
cœur et leurs esprits ne faisaient qu'un
si leur amitié est légendaire c'est
aussi en raison de sa fin tragique
laabessie meurt à 32 ans soit 5 ans
seulement après leur rencontre monteigne
en est bouleversé il admire le discours
de la servitude volontaire au point
qu'il pense l'inclure dans ses Essais
finalement il renonce il trouve le
discours trop scolaire et puis le propos
est controversé pour l'époque surtout
dans le contexte des guerres de religion
qui divisent la France mais la postérité
de Montaigne assurera celle de la boéie
dans les dernières années de sa vie
Montaigne annote un exemplaire de la
première édition des essais il se
demande pourquoi il aimit tant la boéie
il ne sait pas trop il écrit dans la
marge parce que c'était lui parce que
c'était moi après leur relation n'est
pas entièrement spontané comme ils sont
tous les deux fans de la culture de
l'antiquité ils suivent le modèle
antique de l'amitié idéale deux hommes
qui cèdent à grandir intellectuellement
et moralement Ciceron est un des
théoriciens les plus connus de ce modèle
un jour Montaigne fait inscrire en latin
sur le mur de sa bibliothèque l'an du
Christ 1571 à l'âge de 38 ans la veille
des calandes de mars anniversaire de sa
naissance Michel de Montaigne dégoûté
depuis longtemps de l'esclavage de la
cour et des charges publiques se sentant
encore en pleine vigueur vint se reposer
sur le sein des docte vierg dans le
calme et la sécurité il y franchira les
jours qui lui reste à vivre donc à
seulement 38 ans il arrête la politique
il abandonne donne sa charge de
magistrat il se retire sur ses terres et
prévoit de consacrer le reste de ses
jours à l'étude et à la réflexion et
cette décision est si sérieuse pour lui
qu'il crée un rappel permanent dans sa
bibliothèque pour s'interdire tout
retour dans le monde mais pourquoi cette
décision simplement parce qu'il le peut
en effet la mort de son père 2 ans plus
tôt a fait de lui un rentier un riche
rentier Montaigne dispose d'une belle
fortune qui le met complètement à l'abri
du besoin après il devient aussi le
nouveau chef de famille ce qui fait
qu'il endosse la responsabilité de tout
le patrimoine il va devoir gérer les
1000 petites affaires et transactions
journalières du domaine il a aussi les
soucis d'un père de famille mais bon il
a quand même beaucoup de temps à
consacrer à lui-même pardon pour
l'interruption mais j'ai une question à
vous poser vous croyez vraiment que les
gens ont lu tous les livres dont ils
parlent bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand-chose et
oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée et
il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le
chien donc le secret de la culture
générale ce n'est pas de lire des livres
c'est quoi alors en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a cinq les étudiants
et les personnes les plus cultivés les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets vous savez vous avez lu
Renant comme moi mais il se gardent bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'ils appliquent les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet ils brillent par
leur culture dans les conversations et
dans les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver 10 fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites-le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier
secret sec qui vous attendra bien au
chaud dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo la customisation de la
bibliothèque de Montaigne ne se résume
pas au rappel de sa décision qu'il fait
inscrire sur le mur il fait également
peindre des maximes latines sur les
poutres son idée c'est que quand il
lèvera les yeux il apercevra des
formules de sagesse apaisantes c'est un
peu de l'autoconditionnement parmi la
cinquantaine de formules il y en a une
seule en français que sais-je c'est la
devise de Montaigne en emblématique de
son approche sceptique maintenant vous
savez d'où vient le nom de la fameuse
collection de petits livres mais
pourquoi est-ce qu'il va aussi loin dans
la customisation de sa bibliothèque et
bien parce qu'il y passe l'essentiel de
son temps de 38 à 48 ans Montaigne
investit la plupart de ses heures dans
la tour du château qui abrite sa
bibliothèque il a de quoi lire parce
qu'il a hérité de la belle bibliothèque
de laabessie mais il ne suit aucun
programme il ouvre le volume qui
l'intéresse sur le moment et la note de
temps à autre il écrit quelques pensées
il n'a aucun but aucun plan son esprit
vagabonde d'un sujet à l'autre jusqu'à
ce qu'il réalise que toutes ces notes
convergent vers une idée il s'étudie
lui-même il dit au début des essais
qu'il ne cherche pas le plaisir du
lecteur ni sa propre gloire ce qu'il
veut c'est que ses parents au sens large
puissent mieux le connaître mais
l'intérêt de son livre dépassera très
largement son ambition initiale car en
apprenant à connaître Montaigne c'est
l'homme qu'on apprend à connaître les
essais vont devenir une sorte de Manuel
de la condition humaine qui se connaît
connaît aussi les autres écrit Montaigne
car chaque homme porte la forme entière
de l'humaine
condition rester de longues heures à
lire et à écrire ça endommage le corps
et à l'époque de Montaigne il n'y a pas
de sièges adaptés ni de bureaux debout
beaucoup des rudis ont donc des
problèmes de santé Montaigne ne fait pas
exception ils souffre notamment de
calcul biliaire ce sont de petits
cailloux durs qui se forment dans un
petit sac près de son foie appelé
vésicule biliaire ça lui fait très mal
au ventre notamment après les repas ça
empêche de voyager parce que les
douleurs sont encore pire à cheval mais
mon préfère souffrir sur son cheval que
dans son lit à 48 ans après 10 ans
d'isolement volontaire il entame donc un
voyage qui le tiendra éloigné pendant
presque 2 ans de sa femme de sa tour de
sa patrie et de son travail c'est long
parce que Montaigne s'y prend avec le
livre du monde comme avec les livres de
sa bibliothèque il ne suit aucun
programme il veut juste satisfaire son
immense curiosité il rencontre beaucoup
de gens peu importe leur condition
sociale des aristocrates des paysans des
commerçants il discutent avec des
religieux protestants comme
il multiplie les expériences il assiste
à l'exécution d'un criminel se fait
inviter par une famille juive à une
circoncision visite des bibliothèques
fréquente les Bains à ses yeux goûter la
diversité du monde est la meilleure
école qui soit Montaigne aime bien les
livres mais comme il l'explique dans les
essais la vérité du monde n'est pas dans
les livres elle est dans le
monde une surprise attend Montaigne à
son retour de voyage les citoyens de
Bordeaux l'ont choisi pour MRE attendez
il ne s'est pas présenté et ça fait 11
ans qu'il a abandonné sa responsabilité
de conseiller municipal qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé et bien les essais ont paru
un an plus tôt et ils ont rendu
Montaigne célèbre les Bordelais veulent
donc que cet homme si sage devienne leur
mère bien sûr Montaigne est flatté mais
comme il chérit sa liberté il refuse
lorsqu'il arrive au château il trouve
une lettre du roi le souhaet des
citoyens de Bordeaux n'est plus une
simple demande c'est une offre qu'il n'a
pas le droit de refuser Montaigne
devient donc maire de Bordeaux en 1581
et les bordelais ne sont pas mécontents
de lui parce qu'à l'expiration de son
mandat il est réélu pour de années
supplémentaires
nous sommes en 1584 au cours du 2 mandat
de ma de Bordeaux Henry de Navar le
futur roi de France Henri
débarque au domaine de Montaigne et bien
sûr il ne débarque pas tout seul il a
une escorte de 40 chevaliers avec tous
leurs domestiqu il dort dans le propre
lit de Montaigne le rapport de force est
posé mais le futur roi n'est pas là pour
raquetter Montaigne il a besoin de son
talent de diplomate en effet avec sa
grande tolérance Montaigne est un
médiateur idéal non seulement il a
l'esprit de l'emploi mais il a aussi la
position c'est l'époque des guerres de
religion Henri de Navar est censé
succéder au roi en exercice Henri II
seulement voilà Henry de Navar est
protestant donc s'il ne trouve pas un
accord avec le roi en titre une nouvelle
guerre civile paraît inévitable
l'utilité de Montaigne dans cette
histoire c'est qu'il a la confiance des
deux hommes il sert donc d'agent de la
diplomatie secrète entre les deux camps
il fera pour cela des allers-retours
entre Bordeaux et Paris au cours des
prochaines
années nous sommes en 1585 soit la
dernière année du second mandat de M de
Montaigne cet échéant s'approche il va
probablement pouvoir se retirer avec les
honneurs il a bien géré Bordeaux
notamment en la protégeant des tensions
religieuses mais un problème plus grave
survient la peste la moitié de la
population de Bordeaux meurt en moins de
6 mois il se passe un peu la même chose
que ce que nous avons connu récemment
les privilégiés prennent la fuite tandis
que les gens ordinaires se cloîtrent
chez eux la peste parvient jusqu'au
château de Montaigne alors le maire
prend la fuite avec sa famille affolé il
abandonne sa propriété au au pillard il
laisse la gestion de la ville à des
responsables locaux exaspérés par sa
fuite ils lui écrivent lettre sur lettre
jusqu'à ce que son mandat expire mais
Montaigne guide la caravane de sa
famille dans un contexte catastrophique
il peut finalement rentrer au château au
bout de 6 mois cette anecdote révèle la
nature égocentrique de Montaigne il
n'est pas du tout prêt à se sacrifier
pour sa communauté il met sa propre
santé au premier plan en même temps il a
pas demandé à être mère sa fuite a
évidemment entacher sa réputation
Montaigne n'est pas un héros mais il n'a
jamais prétendu être un héros contraire
il est bien conscient de ses défauts il
les confesse dans les
essais si vous aimez l'esprit de cette
vidéo à savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielle sur l'histoire
de l'humanité sur l'histoire de France
en économie en science politique en
psychologie en sciences en littérature
en art en religion et en philosophie
vous ne serez plus jamais à cours de
choses à dire et vous gagnerez la
confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstance vous pouvez en savoir
plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche mais je pense que
la meilleure façon de vous donner une
idée du programme est d'écouter ce que
les membres ont à en dire Valentine qui
reconnais l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence m'écrit directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres est pertinent et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplommate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusé vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré partie de
ce programme et je serai ravi qu'il en
soit de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1idé de
culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la
[Musique]
pensée